desde este miércoles trescientos sesenta
mil niños y niñas en francia- de 5 a 11
años podrán recibir sus primeras dosis
de la vacuna contra el coronavirus esto
incluye a los que padecen afecciones
subyacentes como problemas cardíacos
respiratorios asma grave diabetes u
obesidad
para mí fue muy importante porque mae
lis es una niña que cuando está enferma
las cosas pueden ser muy difíciles de
manejar muy complicadas la mayor parte
del tiempo necesita ir al hospital y
estar bajo tratamiento
no le gusta esto y eso puede ser
complicado porque ella se resiste por lo
tanto esto es un alivio
los menores de 12 años que viven con
personas vulnerables o con sistemas
inmunológicos debilitados también son
elegibles recibirán la vacuna pzifer
pero una dosis más baja que los adultos
en lugar de inyectar los 30 microgramos
que se administran a los adultos 10
microgramos serían suficientes para
ellos francia ya ha pedido 2 millones de
dosis adicionales este mes y en enero se
entregarán otro millón se espera que el
gobierno abra la vacunación a todos los
niños de forma voluntaria pero aún
aguarda el visto bueno de las
autoridades sanitarias la idea se
presentó en noviembre después de recibir
la aprobación del regulador europeo de
medicamentos la vacunación para menores
de 12 años se abrió en grecia hungría y
españa este miércoles en alemania
algunos médicos comenzaron a administrar
sus primeras inyecciones desde el martes